box wars really feels like a medieval
battle the only difference is this with
cardboard
[Music]
there's rules to box wars but they're
very limited there's no winners we like
to say that if you're in a box Wars bad
you've already lost
[Music]
I'm Ross I'm one of the supreme
overlords of box Wars box Wars is a
collective of people that love to get
together create cardboard creations and
then destroy them in an epic battle it's
more about competitiveness in being
creative the only materials that you can
use cardboard adhesives like tape hot
glue whatever you can find in packaging
that's the stuff that we like to use to
build our suits every single battle has
a new engineering challenge like
building a giant aircraft carrier or
building a monster truck that actually
rolls or a train which has to carry in a
whole bunch of policemen we encourage
people to come down to our events and
build as elaborate costumes as they can
possibly make
once they've build the props then we all
gather at a park and then we battle
everyone comes in and clashes and
destroys everything stuff that we've
spent weeks on designing it's all gone
in seconds it just started off really
small but then all the sudden it blew up
there's generally around about 50 to 100
people in the actual battle and then it
can be hundreds and hundreds of
spectators we've got chapters that have
started up all around the world we've
had groups in Japan in Europe and
America in Canada
it seems so childish but it's fantastic
that a concept like this crosses
cultural and language barriers
Vauxhall's is based around comedy that's
the whole point of box wars we're losers
what we're doing is quite pathetic we
should all have real jobs but here we
are building stuff out of cardboard if
you laugh at us that's exactly what we
one
[Music]
[Music]